bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat une semaine après les
assises du cinéma organisée par le cnc
pour évoquer la question du financement
du film français c'est au tour de la
commission de la culture du sénat de
s'emparer de ce sujet avec une table
ronde sur l'économie du film français
table ronde qui intervient en pleine
polémique sur le montant des cachets des
artistes français jugé parfois trop
élevé même quand les films se soldent
par des échecs
alors sans plus tarder ces tables rondes
bonne fin de journée à tous mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs avant
de procéder à cette audition qui je m'en
réjouis a réuni tous les groupes
politiques je vous rappelle un point de
l'ordre du jour qui est une approbation
de la candidature de madame françoise
cartron pour rapporter sur orientation
et programmation pour la refondation de
l'école de la république
y at il d'autres candidatures y at il
des contestations à cette proposition je
peux là considérée comme acceptée par
notre commission je vous en remercie je
souhaite la bienvenue à nos différents
intervenants je les remercie de leur
présence au sénat il y a maintenant un
mois la tribune dans le monde du
producteur vincent maraval a provoqué
une tempête de réactions et beaucoup de
conversations au café du commerce
il faisait le constat que le film
français condamné à ne pas être rentable
ma première pensée a été de me dire que
c'était la raison même de son mode de
financement par tissu de la fiscalité
culturelle mais il appuie son analyse
sur un autre argument selon lui c'est le
salaire des acteurs et réalisateurs que
l'on finance et non pas la diversité de
la création qui est pourtant notre
véritable objectif
autrement dit et même si maraval ne le
dit pas avec ces mots là les films à
gros budget ne financerait pas les films
plus originaux ou plus ambitieux au
contraire il serait même finalement
financé par des films à petit budget qui
rencontrent du succès sans parler du
fond cette tribune a eu au moins un
mérite celui d'ouvrir le débat très
intéressant sur l'économie du cinéma
français auquel l'ensemble de la
profession a participé notamment par
voie de presse
en organisant aujourd'hui cette table
ronde notre objectif n'est pas d'évoquer
le montant ni le mode de financement
global du cinéma français que la
commission de la culture soutient
pleinement
nous abordons un sujet plus précis celui
du financement de chaque film est dans
ce sujet nous nous pencherons de manière
encore plus précises sur les postes de
dépense des salaires des acteurs les
marges des producteurs le budget
marketing quelques interrogations
pourraient constituer la trame de notre
réflexion le coût des films français est
il trop élevé par rapport à notre
capacité de financement
pourquoi les acteurs français sont payés
davantage dans les films français que
dans les films américains
les chaînes de télévision sont elles
responsables de l'envolée des cachets du
star system l'indexation des salaires
sur la réussite des films est elle une
solution
quel est le rôle des agents artistiques
et attendez vous une action des pouvoirs
publics
peut-être en imposant plus de
transparence aux contrats qui lient les
intervenants allons nous avons la chance
d'avoir à nos côtés michel hazanavicius
réalisateur président de la société
civile des auteurs réalisateurs
producteurs là monsieur thomas langmann
producteur et monsieur vincent perez ne
vous a pas abandonné il arrive il est
dans son plexi acteurs
madame elisabeth tener présidente du
syndicat des agents artistiques et
littéraires
et monsieur frank weber directeur des
acquisitions du cinéma français du
groupe canal+ donc nous avons essayé de
vous présenter tous les maillons de
cette chaîne de la confection d'un film
ils vont vous donner leur expertise
d'usagé leurs commentaires un peu par
rapport à la tribune maraval par rapport
aux questions qui peuvent sortir de
cette tribune donc merci de nous
éclairer et je donne en premier la
parole à michel hazanavicius
bonjour donc là vous allez poser
quelques questions en vrac vos jeux je
connais pas exactement la nature de ce
que vous attendez de nos demandes
d'intervention mon jeu ni combien de
temps vous avez vous attendez à ce que
je parle allés chacun 5 à 10 minutes
pour ouvrir le paysage après ils vont en
avoir plein de questions mais
effectivement je pense que ce sera sans
doute plus productif avec des questions
précises plusieurs choses
enfin vous êtes la commission culturelle
donc je ne pense pas à vous convaincre
de l'importance de la culture et de
l'importance des films notamment dans
une société comme la nôtre est dans une
démocratie en général
donc ça c'est déjà on va gagner une
heure je pense ça c'est plutôt les
ensuite pendant et brest 2-2
on suit la tribune de maraval à laquelle
vous faisiez allusion effectivement
est-ce que vous en avez tiré c'était des
questions qui concernait la rentabilité
des films et l'inflation du coût des
films j'ai apprécié que c'est une
manière de voir les films et que quand
on les fesses et c'est pas c'est à ce
qui nous meut principalement je parle
dans mon cas je pense que je suis pas
seul voilà la rentabilité défi mais
d'une manière générale d'ailleurs en
vous écoutant quand vous parlez du coût
des fines de la rentabilité des films
etc
c'est très compliqué de mettre les films
tous dans le même et au monde un même
panier parce qu'il ya vraiment
pratiquement autant d'économies qu'il ya
deux films chaque film c'est un peu un
conte diakiss et de le dire mais chaque
film est un prototype
c'est à dire que si on savait ce qu'il
allait rapporter et si on connaissait
ses capacités auprès du public
vous pensez bien que il y aurait pas de
problème de rentabilité ni de problème
d'inflation des films puisque on saurait
les évaluer dans un marché comme celui
des yaourts ou celui des produits
manufacturés ce n'est pas du tout le cas
c'est ce qui fait un peu tout là toute
la difficulté du film il me semble que
c'est intéressant tu décides réfléchir à
la désinflation des films est
effectivement pour une des raisons que
vous avez cités c'est que l'inflation
des fines a priori engendre une crise de
concentration des budgets sur un nombre
assez limité de films sur lequel on
essaye de fonctionner sur des présumées
recettes et je crois que même ces films
là ont besoin de films plus petit de
fait dans des économies plus modeste
avec peut-être un peu moins de
contraintes de rentabilité ce qu'il veut
ce qu'il veut pas dire que j'ai des
certitudes sur cette rentabilité mais
pour dire que l'économie
rich delphine a besoin de l'économie
prolétaires définiront les gros films
ont besoin de talents qui émergent dans
des films plus petit que ce soit
compagne de l'acteur qu'on parle d'eux
deux réalisateurs qu'on parle de
producteurs aux coupables de scénaristes
donc l'inflation des films un peu
tendance sans doute à tuer la la classe
moyenne des films donc donc voilà donc
je crois que c'est intéressant de
réfléchir à la désinflation des films
pour aller donc pour continuer cette
discussion là sur le sur les acteurs et
la tribune de maraval
je pense qu'il faudrait il faut pas je
crois un des cerises à un désolidariser
les acteurs des autres ayants droits des
films et quand je parle des ayants droit
je parle aussi bien des producteurs qui
sont intéressés réellement recettes des
films que dès que des talents soient
producteurs qu'ils soient réalisateur
scénariste ou acteurs et même dans
certains cas des équipes techniques et
des industries techniques qui elles
aussi peuvent être intéressé s'il y
avait un intéressement
comment diable qui fonctionne qui
marchent efficace aux intérêts du film
je pense que beaucoup d'entre nous
jouerait la carte des participations
comme elle est proposée à la fin d'une
de la tribune de maraval le problème
étant et c'est pas un c'est ce n'est pas
du tout un problème nouveau
sa date d'au moins 40 ans lorsque je les
invite à regarder une interview d'yves
montand que vous trouverez sur le site
de l'ina où il explique exactement la
même problématique à peu près dans les
mêmes termes
quand les recettes ne remonte pas les
ceux qui peuvent se font payer en amont
et refuse de faire payer en aval donc il
ya quand même il reste sans doute plus
de transparence qui ça passe pas
nécessairement par les pouvoirs publics
c'est aussi des usages mais la
transparence sur la les remontées de
recettes elles sont pas en revenir plus
précisément dessus si vous voulez après
mais cette transparence là je pense
pourrait
influer sur la désinfection des films je
boude un peu au hasard sur ce que vous
avez dit vous avez parlé beaucoup les
acteurs amérique pourquoi les acteurs
français se seraient plus payés en
france que aux états unis ce bon ça vous
moi personnellement ça me semble évident
ces deux marchés qui sont très très
différents que quelqu'un qui est pardon
du môme est leader dans son marché et ne
l'est pas nécessairement dans un marché
qui est peu gros et qu'il a de toute
façon tout intérêt à faire à paris sont
passionnantes sur le marché américain
qui de toute façon va le renforcer sur
le marché français donc c'est un
investissement qui font il est à mon ami
plein de bon sens enfin je ne vois pas
bien ce jeu j'ai du mal à mettre de la
morale ou de la vertu là dedans
d'ailleurs d'une manière générale je
trouve que le procès qui était fait avec
ceux ci d'un peu perverse était que je
crois que d'une manière générale on ne
peut pas demander à des individus
d'avoir plus de vertus que ce que le
système permet en fait donc ça tout ça
semble assez normal et vous allez
terminer en demandant ce qu'on attendait
des pouvoirs publics sur les problèmes
qui ont été posées par vincent maraval
moi personnellement je vois pas vraiment
ce que les pouvoirs publics peut faire
par contre les jeux il me semble que
dans sur l'économie du cinéma
les enjeux à venir sont pas vraiment là
les enjeux à venir
lorsque vous avez tous conscients c'est
quand même comment c'est l'arrivée du
numérique et comment le numérique change
bouleverse révolutionne le le le
notamment la diffusion des films c'est
surtout là où parce que ce show sur la
fabrication des filles ça fait bien
longtemps que tout le monde a accepté
adopté que ce soit de l'écriture au fil
image aux effets spéciaux etc
on travaille tous au numérique il n'y a
pas de problème la diffusion pose
beaucoup de problèmes parce que parce
qu'elle bouleverse les équilibres et les
forces des des diffuseurs qui dans le
système que vous connaissez sont
justement les financiers du du cinéma
donc c'est intéressant de d'obliger les
diffuseurs à financer le cinéma
s'ils tentaient qui sont aussi protégés
et aujourd'hui avec cette notamment
internet il ya quand même une
fragilisation de ces diffuseurs
traditionnels donc là je crois qu'il ya
une responsabilité politique pour faire
comment dire intégrer harmonieusement
ces nouveaux acteurs du numérique et
d'internet à notre système qui est
français mais qui aurait tout à gagner à
être exportée sous voulez mon ami et
voilà la liane la hem
je crois que les pouvoirs publics
peuvent poser peuvent peser un non
seulement en termes franco français mais
surtout en
en travaillant à bruxelles aussi parce
qu'en face les géants du net qui
s'appelle amazon apple google et ses
terrasses et des entreprises alors là
c'est de l'argent privé pur et dur et
c'est des entreprises pratiquement aussi
puissante que des états il faut quand
même le savoir et qui alors qu'il a une
prime de la fiscalisation des annonces
se pose mais qui pour le coup on est des
puissances de lobbying qu'est la côte et
nous on est vraiment des foetus coiffe
un jeune héros mais on n'est pas du tout
du tout dans la même catégorie
donc en france on a quand même un
pouvoir politique qui voilà qui
fonctionne là je crois qu'on a nous
avons besoin de vous voilà merci
rassurez vous c'est vous qui êtes
invités c'est pas google et amazon jours
n'y a que les sollicitations sont très
fortes pour les gets par la porte et
cherche à rentrer par la fenêtre mais
serez vous c'est vous que nous
souhaitons écoutez merci monsieur thomas
langmann et vice président de l'union
des producteurs français
je lui donne volontiers la parole de
suite
ouais
donc bonjour merci de nous recevoir mais
je suis assez d'accord avec quasiment
tout ce qu'a dit michel pour compléter
un petit peu ses propos
moi je pense que les puisqu'on a je
reprends aussi les les propos de la
présidente le maraval guèye tel qu'on
l'a appelé enfin les propos de vincent
maraval pour moi me semble assez
conjoncturel en ce qui le concerne
puisque et c'est un ami on a travaillé
avec lui j'aime beaucoup donc je parle
de ces propos ils payent pas de lui
c'est sûr que c'est une société
indépendante donc à traverser une
période difficile avec un film un
important ce qui certainement le fait
qu'ils se posent des questions
deux parmi ces questions il est question
sont certainement bonne les réponses
sont pas vraiment d'accord en ce qui me
concerne je pense que d'une part par
rapport aux comparaisons de de ce qu'il
a fait sur les salaires de d'acteurs
américains et d'acteurs français
c'est très difficile de comparer les
acteurs américains prennent pour ce qui
est des stars puisque c'étaient les
stars qui étaient visées prennent sur
des films des salaires qui peuvent en un
film leur permettre de vivre près
quasiment toute une vie donc ensuite de
faire des films plus indépendants plus
hauteur et ils ont bien compris depuis
longtemps que des carrières comme celle
de johnny depp ou plein d'autres il
alterne des films grand public et des
films hauteur et que souvent les films
d'auteur leur permettent d'avoir une
image qui leur permettent d'avoir des
prix est souvent d'ailleurs deux de
plaire à des publics européens et des
non-américains donc donc ensuite c'est
très facile de comparer avec un film où
johnny depp a touché 200 mille dollars
en oubliant celui à côté où l'on a pris
60 donc
donc ça c'est qu'on par exemple ne me
semblent pas bonnes ensuite
l'inflation du duduk du coût des acteurs
elle et elle est réelle
maintenant les causes de cette inflation
pour moi elles viennent d'une chose
c'est que le cinéma est victime d'une
chose en france c'est de son succès
puisque le système que vous avez mis en
place afin que les institutions ont su
mettre en place d'obligations de toutes
les dispositions la création du cnc jeu
ont font que notre cinéma est un cinéma
unique et est extrêmement énergique et
vivant et qu'il a d'ailleurs tout une
grâce à ses obligations notamment et aux
vocations différentes des chaînes je
pense à la vocation par exemple de
france télévisions qui évidemment
différente de celle des chaînes privées
à l'intérieur même du cnc il ya
différents types de systèmes et dead qui
privilégie des cinémas différents et que
cette variété de cinéma est une des
spécificités qui est enviée dans le
monde entier
en tout cas par les créateurs de films
et que donc elle et elle est bonne à la
parfois des excès des travers j'ai moi
même souligné ç'avait été un petit peu
sorti de son contexte ou surexposées
quand je je je mettais en cause l'avancé
sur recette tout simplement parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle a été créée et elle
doit le rester et c'est une précise que
c'est une infime part du budget du cnc
puisque je pense qu'elle concerne 20 à
30 millions d'euros sur un budget qui
est de plus de 200 fin de 700 millions
et qu'évidemment à l'époque elle a été
fait pour privilégier un cinéma d'auteur
ou un cinéma plus difficiles à faire et
donc elle doit à mes yeux garder cette
vocation
je m'étais juste en avant que parfois il
fallait que les les créateurs qui
déposent des des projets puissent venir
les défendre parce que quand nous avons
fait dix artistes
ou police où la guerre est déclarée ou
j'en oublie mais cette année là aucun ou
intouchables aucun de ses films n'a
bénéficié de l'avancé sur recettes donc
il sait qu'il ya une erreur mais qui me
semble est conjoncturelle est d'ailleurs
eric garandeau a suite aux propos réuni
une commission qui a pris d'aider des
réformes concernant l'avant sur recettes
et donc de ce point de vue là de mon
côté je n'ai plus rien à dire en tout
cas pour revenir sur le salaire des
acteurs ou des metteurs en scène
le problème est qu'ils aient l'écho que
cahuc a donné évidemment parce que pour
la presse vous le savez bien c'est un
petit peu du pain bénit que de mettre en
avant des des figures connues telles que
des stars qu'on a en france qu'on n'a
pas besoin de nommer qu'eux qui celle
qui était nommé dans toutes les
histoires de des propos liés à maraval
et donc il ya toutes sortes d' amalgame
qui ont été issus de ça je pense que la
vraie raison qui donne lieu à cette
inflation c'est qu'effectivement c'est
pour ça que disait qu'on est victime de
notre succès il ya encore quinze à vingt
ans il y avait grosso modo quelques
groupes qui sont d'ailleurs toujours là
et dieu merci que des groupes français
comme gaumont comme pathé donc jérôme
seydoux et nicolas seydoux qui sont des
des gens qui font du cinéma avec passion
et qui n'oublie pas que c'est quand même
une économie à part puisque le cinéma
coûte cher donc il faut évidemment le le
fer avec passion mais ne pas oublier que
ça une rentabilité est nécessaire voire
vital et il y avait quatre cinq
producteurs disant indépendants capables
d'aller se concurrencer sur les films
qui sont disons sur le papier des films
qui peuvent intéresser les chaînes
privées et les distributeurs qui depuis
se sont aussi multipliées aujourd'hui
vous avez en plus de ces acteurs là et
des majors américaines
une vingtaine de producteurs
indépendants dans lesquels je m'inclus
qu'ils sont capables de faire des offres
à ses talents là on sait bien que les
stars comme dans le sport ou dans
d'autres domaines sont assez
indispensable
et d'ailleurs je vois je vois pas
comment dans tout ce dont tous les
cinémas du monde entier il ya ce
phénomène de starification est donc
évidemment que pour monter des budgets
importants
il y a dix quinze acteurs je mélange
hommes et femmes qui permettent de
monter des films avec plus de facilité
et donc comme nous avons un grand nombre
de films et bien entre producteurs et
les agents je laisserais elisabeth
tanner s'exprimer évidemment mais on se
tire la bourre
donc franchement ça veut dire que entre
producteurs il ya forcément une
inflation parce qu'on se bat pour avoir
ses talents là je pense que la vraie
raison de l'inflation et de la
multiplication donc des acteurs capables
de faire des offres
et ceci dit cette multiplication la a
aussi des bons côtés puisqu'elle fait
qu'il ya plus de films et que donc il ya
plus de tournage que donc on fait
travailler plus de techniciens et que le
système a les désavantages de ces
avantages le dernier point c'était jeu
ah oui alors effectivement je trouve
dommage avec j'espère que vous aurez la
sagesse effectivement comme dit michel 2
il ya des enjeux plus important à mes
yeux que et des vrais chantiers et qu'il
faudrait pas que la presse qui a
tendance a évidemment beaucoup utilisé
et parfois et d'ailleurs il ya eu
énormément d d'inexactitudes et de
salaire et qu'ils ont été écrits et qui
sont très loin de la réalité j'en prends
deux qui me concerne on a dit que
vincent cassel et je je mets un bémol
c'est bien sûr des sommes très
importantes mais on a dit vincent cassel
avait touché 2 millions d'euros pour
faire les deux films sur jacques mesrine
que j'ai produit et on n'a touché qu'un
et il a travaillé huit mois donc c'est
une somme énorme mais en tout cas c'est
pas 2 c'est un michel hazavanicius et
jean dujardin j'ai lu que jean dujardin
avait touché 2 millions d'euros pour
faire dix artistes il en a fait deux
cent mille donc ensuite il avait un
intéressement qui la mènera peut-être
dans 15 ans à cette somme là mais en
tout cas pour le moment très très loin
de ça donc
et je voudrais vous rappeler l'économie
qui a été celle de dix artistes
c'est une économie qui en dehors de deux
puisque on pourrait parler d'argent
public bombe alors qu'à france
télévisions qui est le seul qui pourrait
être apparenté à de l'argent public
jeudi apparentés parce que d'abord c'est
le film a été extrêmement rentable pour
eux ils ont récupéré tout
l'investissement et au delà de ce qu'ils
avaient investie et ils ont évidemment
la diffusion du film donc
l'investissement de france 3 était d'un
million d'euros et ils ont récupéré au
delà tout le reste du financement de ce
film et de l'investissement privé en
grande partie canal+ warner france sur
37 alors qu'on pourrait suivre 37 c'est
encore un cas à part
mais et la petite reine et le michel
hazavanicius
bérénice bejo et jean dujardin ont
divisé leur salaire de manière très
importante pour permettre au film
d'exister le système du crédit d'impôt
qui est un système est d'ailleurs je me
permets de féliciter les amendements
conte qui sont en train d'être mis en
oeuvre pour aider le cinéma français et
étrangers a tourné dans de meilleures
conditions en france et assure tous
équipés de systèmes dont les autres pays
se sont équipés nous n'avons pas
bénéficier de ce crédit d'impôt
donc nous n'avons pas eu ni de région ni
de crédit d'impôt puisque le sujet
nécessitait de tournée aux états unis
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison je
pense qu'on a réussi à voir cet oscar et
que on a on a respecté le fait que
l'histoire qu'avait écrit michel se
devait puisqu'elle se passait aux états
unis d'être tourné dans les vrais
studios et c'est donc
donc voilà donc il ya beaucoup
d'amalgamés comme le disait michel les
films sont des prototypes
ils sont extrêmement différents et je
veux juste ajouter une dernière chose ou
est ce que les est ce que les films
importants de gros budget aide les plus
petits bien sûr que oui
moi je n'aurais jamais pu faire dix
artistes ou coproduire indigènes ou ou
même mesrine si je faisais pas astérix
ou le boulet jeu prendra en exemple
claude berri mon père qui produisait des
films de patrice chéreau de la reine
margot ils le faisaient aussi parce
qu'il faisait les films des inconnus
parce qu'il faisait gazon maudit donc il
y a cette variété la de cinéma les
producteurs ont besoin de films qui sont
rentables pour pouvoir se permettre
d'aider des films plus difficile voilà
donc je pensais avoir répondu
merci beaucoup bien entendu notre objet
n'est pas de légiférer sur l'économie
interne des montages de films rats se
veut tout de suite tout cas je veux vous
rassurer sur l'intérêt partagé de tous
les groupes politiques de cette
commission afin que nous puissions
trouver des outils sur google amazon et
c'est un texte de loi de l'auteur marini
va d'ailleurs être présenté en séance
demain le rapporteur claude mais elle
était à nos côtés tout à l'heure pour la
commission il n'ira pas plus loin parce
que simultanément il ya le rapport colas
et colas sur l'économie du numérique il
ya la mission lescure il ya plein de
choses dans le paysage il ya la ministre
fleur pellerin qui fait des déclarations
comme quoi elle a une vraie volonté
d'avancer sur le sujet mais nous sommes
vraiment en attente partagée et quant
aux outils du cinéma vous avez pu
constater dans tous les débats
budgétaires précédent que malgré le fort
clivage droite gauche sur ce sujet là
bas la défense du cnc tout ça nous
défendons collectivement
cet outil que du coup c'est des ronds
une pépite indispensable voilà monsieur
vincent perez nous a rejoints je le
remercie de sa présence et je lui donne
la parole ou la plus facile après thomas
langmann qui parle tellement bien du
cinéma était vraiment représentant
magnifique du cinéma français en plus un
cinéma qui s'exporte jeu je suis pas
producteur donc je rejouerai pas je
n'aborde pas le sujet parle par le même
biais sur le
moi il ya il ya une chose qui me meut
avec laquelle je pose le jeu souvent ça
me dérange je peux le dire c'est
pourquoi nos fils nos productions vont
tourner en belgique au luxembourg
parce qu'il ya des facilités qui sont
offertes dans ces pays là et donc du
coup on est on va tourner dans ces pays
là on fait travailler les gens de de la
belgique du sans broncher pas contre
mais du coup on fait peut-être moins
travailler nos techniciens et parfois
acteur français donc moi ça c'était une
des questions je me pose est ce qu'on
pourrait pas trouver en france quelque
chose de similaire enfin pour essayer de
garder nos productions en france aurait
moyen d'empêcher ces films de ceux de
partir dans ce pays là pour faire des
économies
donc ça c'était une de mes questions
l'autre c'est peut-être que je sors un
petit peu des questions qui sont posées
dans le cadre de cette de cette
rencontre
voilà voilà et il ya une mesure 1 m 20
l'autre question aussi que je me posais
parfois j'aborderai en fait les
questions qui sont posées cpo n'y
aurait-il pas moyen de d'accueillir en
france des tournages étrangers de
faciliter un tout petit peu plus leur
venue sur le territoire français de
travailler en france de devenir d'amener
de l'argent en france est passé monde de
venir le chercher pour aller tourner
ailleurs
donc je parle je pense par exemple au
studio 2
le ciné cité où il ya un oeuf immense
studio de 2000 mètres carrés qu'ils sont
c'est un outil formidable
il reste il pas moyen de l'ired
d'encourager les productions étrangères
passez-moi américaine l'étrangère de
devenir en france parce que c'est très
souvent quand je discute avec mes amis
producteurs américains
ils disent non vient pas en france chose
que c'est trop cher donc ça c'était une
petite parenthèse j'imagine
c'est pourquoi les acteurs français sont
ils payés davantage dans les films
français que dans les films américains
parce que comme je connais un petit peu
la question
tout simplement parce que il ya en
france ils ont une bien une caisse de
résonance à partir du moment où il ya un
acteur français connus qui font partie
de la liste des 15 et peut-être il ya
d'ailleurs on a peut-être un peu plus si
si ils sont aussi il joue dans un film
il va y avoir ensuite une sorte de
safran avait fait boule de neige
il peut les médias s'y intéresseront
plus et donc du coup ce sera une caisse
de résonance pour le film donc qui qui
aidera le film a à a existé
j'irai au milieu d'eux des dans les
médias donc je pense que c'est une
valeur c'est les acteurs travaillent des
années pour pour pour arriver à je
dirais représenter quelque chose dans la
production d'un film et dans dans la
promotion d'un film donc comprendre on
ne prend pas seulement le talent de
l'acteur mais aussi ce qu'il représente
pour pour défendre le film ait existé
dans la presse donc je pense que c'est
une valeur
maintenant s'ils sont moins payées dans
les films américains c'est parce que
tout simplement ils ont ils ont pas
cette caisse de résonance dans les
médias là bas
voilà donc ça c'est mon point de vue sur
le sujet maintenant le rôle de l'agent
alors un très bon très bon très bon
exemple ici elisabeth tanner qui est mon
agent moi je sais que mes salaires kiss
kiss qui ne rejoignent pas les salaires
des les élus de parce qu'en fait il ya
on est des périodes où ton coup on est
on est dans le vent on est dans le
succès donc du coup les salaires le 106
de rencontres d'en finir accompagne le
succès moi je ne sais quelle est la bête
à chaque fois elle est concernée par le
budget du film et est injuste
en fait moi personnellement mes cachets
avec la la la la logique de des montages
financiers du film et je pense que un
bon agent devrait fonctionner comme ça
elle le fait elle le fait très bien
peut-être qu'ils ne sont pas tous moi je
peux parler que tu que du mien qui est à
dire qu'il va pas râler après moi je
crois oui donc j'aurai un petit peu à la
question est ce que les chaînes de
télévision surtout responsable de
l'envolée des cachets et du style du sar
systar système je pense que c'est quand
même lit oui je pense que c'est lié
je viens d'en parler donc je vais pas me
répéter
voilà ce que je me pose la question
j'aimerais bien dans des salles et avoir
des réponses que je ne déclarerai pas
par le rapporteur mais sachez que dans
le dernier budget il y à une des
dispositions pour relocaliser les
tournages en france qui sont des
avantages fiscaux qui nous manquait
cruellement mais qui ont été des levier
déterminant pour la belgique
je connais bien mais c'est peut-être
chez moi et où on voit effectivement de
l'autre côté de la frontière à quel
point un tout petit levier peuvent être
déterminants sur la fuite de nos
artistes et techniciens
donc monsieur leleu et rapporteur de
notre commission pour le sujet du cinéma
et quand nous aurons entendu chacun des
intervenants il pourra apporter quelques
précisions
nous allons maintenant entendre la
parole des agents
madame élise et le tonnerre et
d'ailleurs présidente du syndicat des
agents artistiques et littéraires mais
elle est également agent de vincent
perez bonjour merci de nous recevoir
donc comme tout le monde c'est à peu
près exprimé sur le sur le sujet moi je
dirai juste effectivement je suis
d'accord avec thomas sur la tribune de
maraval je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que c'était un
circonstanciel et 2 catégorielles elle a
le mérite de poser le débat donc on le
pose on essaye d'y répondre sur ce que
sur la question de savoir pourquoi les
acteurs ça est ce que les acteurs sont
trop payés bon sur la sur la
rémunération entre les etats-unis la
france je pense que c'est tout le monde
est absolument d'accord sur la mécanique
c'est effectivement quand vous devez
vous avez un film américain qui va
s'adresser finalement marché mondial
vous avez une valorisation de votre
acteur donc c'est ce qu'on appelle un
investissement tout bêtement comme comme
on fait dans l'industrie on investit
donc on est moins payé en espérant avoir
un retour sur investissement et qui
permet de valoriser l'image de l'acteur
temps sur sa possibilité de travailler
sur une cinématographie étrangère plus
importante et suez de se renforcer sur
ce marché intérieur et sur ceux
cinématographie initial on va dire donc
ça je pense que ça de c'était une dans
la tribune de maraval je pense que
c'était une façon un peu opportune de
2,2 de poser des problèmes qu'ils n'en
sont pas puisque tout le monde est
d'accord sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de de deux
problématiques particulières autour de 7
de ce fait là sur la rémunération des
acteurs d'abord représentant un syndicat
donc parlons pour plusieurs agences
j'aimerais juste attirer l'attention
comme globalement du fait que le métier
n'est pas fait que des 15 vedette que
healy a aujourd'hui beaucoup d'acteurs
qui ne gagne pas forcément leur vie ou
qui la gagnent très sporadiquement que
le métier d'acteur est un métier à haut
risque que les carrières vont et
viennent que nous assistons parfois des
gens qui terminent leur carrière à la
roue tourne et sans lesquels ceux qui ne
peuvent plus payer de loyer qui n'ont
plus de maison qui n'ont plus rien donc
il ya un moment donné il faut aussi
admettre que le spectre du cinéma
français et l'industrie du cinéma
français ne ne comporte pas que quinze
15 personnes plus ou moins bien lotis un
parc d'acteurs j'allais dire qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient tout à fait
flamboyant donc je pense aujourd'hui
qu'il ya une vraie question qui le
renouvellement des talons message en
parlerait on en parlera peut-être plus
tard le renouvellement des talents qui
vient d'ailleurs répondre à la
problématique de la concentration sur un
certain nombre d'acteurs j'en parle
d'autant que ayant une clientèle plutôt
sympathique jeu
voilà je n'ai pas de problème
particulier ni personnel mais je
remarque qu'il ya une difficulté
aujourd'hui à renouveler les talons et
avec des carrières qui sont peut-être
plus volatiles qu'avant voilà donc ça
c'est la première remarque sur le
l'économie globale des salaires
d'acteurs il est évident que je ne crois
pas qu'on soit dans un pays masochiste
ligne et dans un métier masochiste donc
à partir du moment où certains acteurs
ont ces salaires à là c'est qu'ils le
méritent
il le mérite pourquoi j'avais adoré la
formule de thomas d'ailleurs c'est on
paye un footballeur mais on lui demande
mais on sait pas avant le match il a
tiré six villes civ s il va marquer des
buts c'est pas tout à fait faux c'est à
dire qu'on est dans une économie où on
est le financement se fait en amont et à
partir de là tout le monde espère effet
une promesse est un pari sur l'avenir du
film on sait évidemment que un certain
nombre d'acteurs permettent de lever le
financement ils ne sont pas les seuls il
ya le projet dans sa globalité ce qu'on
appelle la cohérence du projet qui fait
que un acteur à une place plus ou moins
prépondérante dans dans dans le film
dans la cohérence du film il arrive
parfois que l'élément déterminant soit
le metteur en scène jeu
et si le metteur en scène un projet de
film avec un conte qui n'est pas énorme
à partir de là le metteur en scène aura
une certaine liberté de casting est ce
qui peut permettre d' ailleurs
l'avènement justement par ce biais là
l'avènement de nouveaux talents
quand je dis de nouveaux talents s'est
rarement des inconnus totaux jeu
j'essaye aussi d'expliquer quand même
que le métier d'acteur ça m'était qui ce
qui est en gestation et avec une période
de préparation de deux d'expérimentation
et c est que quand on dit des nouveaux
talents ici il ya rarement des
générations spontanées de nouveaux
acteurs sur donc sur cet ajustement des
cachets des acteurs ou à l'économie des
films elle me paraît tout à fait
évidente quand on a un film à gros
budget on va chercher une grosse vedette
on va chercher effectivement sa
valorisation d'image
d'une part pour arriver à exister dans
les médias
alors pourquoi exister dans les médias
il ya deux raisons essentielles la
première c'est qu'un film doit créer sa
marque et que sa marque c'est de sa
marque et de la force de sa marque va
dépendre l'enchaînement des
exploitations prévu sur le film que ce
soit la vidéo le passage télé etc etc
qu'à ce titre la valorisation de la
marque il est évident que c'est un peu
plus simple de la faire quand on a des
acteurs qui vont pouvoir se déplacer sur
les supports papier sur les journaux
télévisés sur les grosses émissions de
télévision populaires etc etc
donc cette valorisation là en tant qu
elle on l'a fait jouer immédiatement
évidemment la deuxième chose c'est que
globalement le box office des acteurs
précédent enfin précédent l'as temps de
la négociation est important aussi et
qu' il y aura évidemment une
valorisation dans la mesure où on dit je
pense que tu es l'artiste a fait telle
est l entrée jusqu'à présent et donc je
pense qu'il ya une confiance du public
par rapport à cet acteur qui fait que y
aura peut-être un effet de suivi alors
aujourd'hui on nous fait toujours
constaté qu' il ya des catastrophes
industrielles qu'il ya des accidents
industriels
on est dans une économie de prototype
moi même quand je négocie je ne sais pas
toujours parfois quand on est très en
amont ne s'est pas très bien ce qui va
se passer m'est arrivé de revoir en
accord avec le producteur l'ensemble du
contrat de la rémunération des
différentes
en droit à la baisse ça ne t'arrive pas
apte à tomates et je te jure que ça
t'arrive plus souvent qu'à mon tour en
ce moment parce que la promesse de
financement n'est pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'avaient envisagé le producteur donc
on vient nous demander de effectivement
baisser la voix lyon selon la formule
consacrée
donc donc je pense que l'ajustement il
est assez légitime il se fait assez
normalement et il est évident qu'il ya
un ou deux films ou trois films par an
qui de tous ceux de temps en temps
dysfonctionne on va dire alors
dysfonctionne pourquoi c'est parce que
quand on les lit on comprend pas
pourquoi ils sont financés
on a tout à coup une vedette qui se dit
j'ai besoin de payer mes impôts donc ben
je vais faire un film de plus
et du coup comme il ya une vedette qui
est là on se dit bon ça se prend pas de
risques donc on en voit d'autres gens
sur sur le film et voilà il ya de temps
en temps des films je ne citerai pas je
pense que tout le monde en a en tête ici
pas le même jeu dire mais on a tous un
film comme ça en tête ça arrive mais
c'est un dysfonctionnement tout les tous
les ans on va dire globalement donc je
ne pense pas qu'ils aient des gros
scandale à ce niveau là après que enfin
en tout cas c'est mon point de vue et
voilà donc sur sur le
alors après ce que je voulais dire aussi
c'est que quand je dis que j'aimerais
qu'on s'ajuste à l'économie des films
c'est qu'effectivement ce qui est
intéressant est effectivement je suis
bien placé puisque je suis au milieu de
tous les intervenants ici c'est que il
ya des films aujourd'hui on a une
diversité de films c'est à dire que on a
des films à très petit budget on a des
films à gros budget on a des films du
milieu qui sont peut-être ceux qui sont
plus en souffrance je vais pas revenir
sur les tribunes de pascale ferran et
autres mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un
système il ya un certain type de film
sur du mal à se financer aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils sont les considère un tout
petit peu trop chers qui sont pas tout à
fait dans la bonne case et qu'on a du
mal à les rentrer dans des cases dit de
financement plutôt que qu'autre chose
mais cette diversité du cinéma je la
trouve extrêmement essentiel tout à
l'heure thomas parler des acteurs
américains qui jongle entre des films à
grand succès et des films peut-être plus
auteurs
c'est aussi ce qui arrive en france
parce que la valorisation d'un acteur
elle passe aussi par des prix par des
reconnaissances que ce soit les césar
les festivals internationaux et c'est
donc cette oscillation de l'artiste
entre des films à petits budgets des
films à gros budget elle existe aussi en
france allez nécessaire elle permet à
des réalisateurs du coup d'émerger
fortement et jeu
je pense que ce n'est qu'une très bonne
chose pour le cinéma français est donc
cette diversité là est bien lié au
système de financement du cinéma
français donc donc que je trouve tout à
fait vertueux et sur lequel on peut
toujours réfléchir je pense que tous les
uns les autres sommes suffisamment
disons au taquet pour se positionner
nous-mêmes et faire notre autocritique
quand il quand il est besoin après sur
la remontée des recettes puisque la
question avait été posée sur pourquoi
les pourquoi on prend tout de suite et
qu'on veut pas faire confiance à à la
véritable exploitation du film je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs systèmes qui qui
coexistent je pense qu'il ya des moments
on sait juste vraiment à la remontée de
recettes
c'est lé moment où justement les
promesses de financement sont fragiles
sont faibles donc on est obligé d'être
sur la réalité de l'exploitation c'est à
dire ne pas ne pas laisser filer une
exploitation qui serait au dessus de ce
qu'on a espéré ou de ce qu'on a évalué
donc là dans ces cas là les les choses
fonctionnent plutôt bien après se pose
évidemment le problème de la
transparence de la remontée des recettes
mais je pense qu'on en parlera peut-être
plus tout à l'heure j'ai entendu michel
hazanavicius qui l'a évoquée je sais que
thomas n'est pas tout à fait d'accord
sur la question
je pense que là dessus effectivement il
ya plusieurs cas de figure encore une
fois un film c'est une histoire et sa
propre histoire et c'est très difficile
de tirer vraiment des lignes générales
il ya des partenaires avec lesquels on
est en confiance et avec lesquels pas
pour des raisons personnelles ou autres
pour des raisons structurelles
il ya des partenaires qui ont fait
confiance parce qu'ils ont la maîtrise
de la remontée des recettes parfois la
multiplicité des partenaires la façon
dont les deals financiers sont faits
font qu' il ya une certaine spoliation
de la recette donc danser dans ces cas
là effectivement on a tendance à prendre
en amont ce qu'on pourrait prendre en
aval et donc la non d'accord souvent ça
touche ces films là justement donc donc
voilà c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il ya
un vrai travail à faire et quant à
attendre quelque chose des pouvoirs
publics
je disais que je pense qu'on était tous
justement d'aider pragmatique on est
tous les jours on est tous les jours les
mains dans le cambouis je pense que tous
les jours on se pose des questions tous
les jours on est face à des cas nouveau
tous les jours on est on a des nouveaux
films qui viennent des nouveaux films
qui arrivent donc tous les jours on
remet on invente des histoires aurait
revendre des contrats on réinvente des
façons d'être rémunérés et c'est sur les
pouvoirs publics j'attends des pouvoirs
publics que ce financement du cinéma
français qui est formidable perdure car
c'est notre intérêt ce un cinéma qui
existent dans le monde entier qui est
notre image et quand on voit aujourd'hui
ce que coûte la la la façon de faire
exister une image pense que c'est tout à
fait dans l'intérêt de la france et que
effectivement la diffusion du numérique
pose problème et qu'il va falloir
effectivement s'attaquer à un autre
fournisseur d'accès entre autres pour
arriver à financer ce qu'on appelle les
contenus voilà merci madame tes nerfs on
a parlé financeurs se frottent weber
vous arriver vraiment à point vous êtes
directeur des acquisitions du cinéma
français du groupe canal+
ça marche
bonjour oui on a en entendez vincent
tout à l'heure de parler des diffuseurs
et des télés bon il ya une multiplicité
de cas de figure
il a vidé télévision je vais je vais
parler surtout de de canal+ qui est un
peu une une des colonnes vertébrales du
système qui est né du système et et de
façon non vertueuse je le pense
interagit avec le système du cinéma du
pij maintenant près de 30 ans la
situation de canal + cd simple c'est une
chaîne privée
certes comme tf1 ou m6 mais payante et
dont les obligations une obligation
principale a à faire avec le cinéma
nous devons
au terme de cette obligation envers ses
douze ennemis % de notre chiffre
d'affaires annuellement annuel
pardon nous et demi pour cent de m le
chiffre d'affaires annuel au cinéma
français en investissement dans des
préachats du préfinancement de films en
gros en amont sur du scénario et sur la
présentation de projets nous
investissons cet argent ça correspond à
170 millions d'euros sur la seule année
2012 pour donner un chiffre
le chiffre le plus récent et nous avons
fait avec ses 170 millions d'euros 110
films que nous avons prêts à acheter
ah les conducteurs comme thomas langmann
mais aussi
des groupes les producteurs indépendants
nous intervenons
c'est très important je reviens pas sur
ce que le disait isabelle est sur une
typologie de films extrêmement diverses
nous nous pouvons nous avons d'abord une
clause de diversité qui fait que un gros
tiers des films que nous prêts achetons
le coup tant de vie moins de 4 millions
d'euros
ce sont des films fragiles en
financement souvent sans casting faut
prendre les exemples de tomboy de la
guerre est déclarée
valérie donzelli qui a une certaine
notoriété au jour d'aujourd'hui était
était inconnu du grand public il ya
encore un an un an et demi
et justement je ne jugerai pas le cnc n
avait pas eu l'avancé sur recettes elles
manquaient d'un financement et de la vue
la région ile de france
bref tout pour être précis mais nous
avons été très heureux de l'accompagner
avec wild bunch vincent maraval et son
producteur et le producteur du film qui
était edouard weil de rectangles le film
nous intervenons sur des films qui
peuvent coûter 1 million d'euros aia a
déclaré comme 30 millions d'euros la
réadaptation de la belle et la bête par
christophe gans avec vincent cassel qui
est en train de il en train de se
tourner en ce moment nous avons donc
vraiment une vision un prisme
extrêmement large lorsqu'il s'agit de
très gros projets il est vrai de ces
projets qui permettront le mettre en
avant
la programmation de canal + auprès de
nos abonnés sam une chaîne privée nous
avons des abonnés des clients nous
sommes très contents d'avoir vincent
cassel qui va incarner évidemment la
bête de cette belle et la bête
lorsque les lorsqu'il s'agit d'un très
grand réalisateur et je prends même
l'exemple pour rebondir sur ce que
disait elizabeth
si jacques audiard vient nous voir avec
ta rain que nous ne connaissons que par
un documentaire où nous l'avons
découvert six mois auparavant là pour le
coup c'est un acteur qui n'a quasiment
pas tourner de films de long métrage
évidemment jacques audiard qui est un
maître de cinéma et que nous respectons
tous nous lisons une confiance absolue
ne nous précipitons sur le film qui
s'appelle un prophète et nous ne sommes
pas déçus car ils révèlent un acteur et
de son talent il fait en émerger un
autre et là encore ce système vertueux
fonctionne fonctionne extrêmement bien
pour revenir sur la polémique des
acteurs à la lequel nous ne participons
pas nous ne voulons pas à participer à
ce que c'est cette une
nous estimons quand même que ce système
reste absolument vertueux nous ne nous
basons sur des devis sur l'adéquation en
train de vie le devis d'un film et le
succès attendu
s'il s'agit d'un tout petit film
évidemment ce sera juste ce sera la
recherche du développement le essayer de
2,2 de trouver ce vivier d'auteurs ne
nous reposerons pas la question du
casting s'il s'agit d'un très gros films
si le devis est très important dans
peut-être que nous maîtriserons un peu
les coûts en donnant une somme un peu
inférieurs à ce qu'ils étaient à pattes
attendu mais nous ne fustigeront pas le
post le poste de l'interprétation dans
le devis qui est celui évidemment les
comédiens comme une fusée genre pas
celui des auteurs ce vil et celui des
techniciens et j'en passe je crois que
ce système est vraiment quelque chose de
bien entendu entre entre tous les
intervenants
il est certain que
je vous parle de ma chaîne privée de
notre chaîne privée le groupe canal nous
avons donc créé 110 films avec 170
millions d'euros
tf1 a fait une quinzaine de films avec
40 millions d'euros avec une ligne
éditoriale et des choix qui sont autres
mais qui sont tout à fait cohérents avec
leur recherche c'est à dire avoir
quelques très grosses comédies
populaires
peut-être un ou deux films policiers
extrêmement bien castés comme on dit
donc il ya une dans cette constellation
des diffuseurs il ya évidemment des
attentes et des recherches qui ne sont
non qui ne sont pas les mêmes d'autant
que par ailleurs le service public
france télévisions qui étaient avec nous
sur ces artistes qui étaient avec nous
sur police l'a cette fois ci c'était
arte c'était ma france 3 françois sur
des artistes art est sûre sur police
nous trouvons très très régulièrement
puisque nous sommes surtout les films a
priori à peu près une autre font très
régulièrement avec avec ses chaînes avec
ses chaînes gratuites
la polémique en terme de philosophie
politique peut être intéressante puisque
voilà l 50 personnes qui sont payés
comme disait thomas s'est énormément
d'argent c'est beaucoup d'argent ça
interroge ça interroge dans un dans un
environnement de crise ça interroge une
société mais l'article était
littéralement centré sur ce sujet là
comme comme nous avions pu le craindre
il ya eu des débordements des
débordements extrêmes on a commencé à
parler de gabegie soit sur les impôts au
public sur les alors que l'on sait très
bien que ces systèmes fonctionnent
extrêmement majoritairement sur d'abord
sur des fonds privés jeu nous en sommes
à j'en suis le j'en suis le garant être
abonné à canal+ aujourd'hui c'est
financer le cinéma français et de façon
privée puisque elle puisque une société
privée mais aussi même la redistribution
du cnc est faite entre les acteurs du
système et ce sont des recettes générées
qui créent des des financements pour
générer de nouvelles recettes qui
créeront des financements et tout ça
paraît extrêmement extrêmement cohérent
et vertueux si on pense que l'exception
culturelle et la survie du cinéma
français qu'on le voit on a vu les
cinématographies anglaise espagnole
quasiment toutes les six minutes
cinématographie allemand de péricliter
quasiment disparaître parce qu'elle
n'avait pas ce système
après c'est un choix de civilisation et
là je parle pour une part pour une
chaîne privée et
et finalement doubler les chiffres mais
voilà si on croit en notre cinéma et
canal
on croit un film d'un million d'euros de
vie comme un film de trente millions on
se dit que chacun dans leur côté peuvent
faire avancer la culture la connaissance
ou même parfois divertir et c'est pas
non plus c'est pas non plus un gros mot
et surtout il faut un autre sens et dès
le départ on a des discussions avec les
producteurs avec thomas avec elizabeth
avec les agents mais d'abord on les a de
façon très diplomatique et
tranquillement entre nous l'idée étant
que les films se fasse et que cette
cinématographie française qui est une
des plus grandes du monde
et assurément nous avons eue grâce à
thomas à michel six oscars il y à il ya
maintenant dix ou onze mois 5
pardon c'était césar si césar c'est ça
j'ai déjà dû intervenir le nombre de ses
deux pires crises moi c'est l'inflation
cinq oscars et nous nous apprêtons avec
michael années que dont je rappelle que
c'est un film français financée entre
autres par canal+ et france 3 d'un
réalisateur certes autrichien mais avec
d'abord qui vient en france
et puis surtout qui est tourné en
français avec jean louis trintignant
emmanuelle riva nous nous apprêtons à
avoir un deux ou trois oscars d'ici
d'ici quelques semaines et au minimum
l'oscar du film étranger
jeu valable pour répondre à cette
polémique je réponds toujours aux
polémiques par quelque chose de beaucoup
plus volontariste et beaucoup plus
joyeux hui le cinéma français et il est
là elle existe et rayonne merci beaucoup
c'est l'heure à porter vive le cinéma
français tout à fait merci madame la
présidente quelques mots assez rapide au
fond puisque on a de nombreux collègues
qui ont certainement des questions à
poser pour dire le sentiment que je me
sens partagé avec ce qu'il me semble
entendre de vos bouches respectives dans
vos filières différentes par rapport à
la polémique je vais y revenir une
petite réponse
en tant que rapporteur et qui est en
apporte heureux puisque c'est une d un
des rares sujets comme le disait la
présidente tout à l'heure qui fait
consensus dans 99% des cas dans notre
commission quelles que soient les bancs
sur lesquels où siégeront donc c'est
plus facile pour un reporter d'être
rapporteur d'une commission consensuel
que quand c'est plus plus plus
conflictuel nous intervenons donc
souvent notamment à l'occasion de la
finance pour défendre le cinéma avec
beaucoup de combativité combative week
en activité mais si un petit élément de
réponse puisque cela fait quelques
années en moins de trois ans peut-être
davantage que nous essayons ici de
réformer le crédit d'impôt est une
réponse à vincent perez tout à l'heure
qui peut-être en tant qu'acteur suit -
les aspects financiers et les intérêts
qui peuvent connaître les productions a
tourné en france plutôt qu'à l'étranger
il y a un grand pas en avant qui a été
fait lors de la dernière loi de finances
et qui a réformé les deux crédits
d'impôt le crédit d'impôt nationale et
le crédit d'impôt est d'un nationale qui
est pour l'international monter au
plafond à 10 millions d'euros
j'avais souhaité personnellement qui
passe encore à 20 c'est pas passé parce
que ces masses mais ce livre on
reviendra on y reviendra l'année
prochaine
je crois que cet élément là de vrais
n'ont pas à payer vos répondre à votre
question nous verrons déjà dans un an
les effets positifs du retour en france
d'un certain nombre de tournages c'est
en tout cas l'objectif et je plaide en
ce qui me concerne pour un crédit
d'impôt rentable rentable pour l'état
j'entends puisque en accordant ce crédit
d'impôt les dépenses qui se font sur le
territoire national sont génératrices
elle même d'une autre fiscalité sociale
ou fiscale qui retombe par un autre
canal dans les caisses de l'état et et
je considère que le crédit d'impôt
cinéma est un crédit d'impôt rentable on
perd d'un côté mais on le récupère
largement de l'autre et c'est ce qui a
été d'ailleurs démontré lors du débat au
sénat
nous interrompons cette table ronde mais
nous reviendrons plus largement dans
notre édition de 19 heures présenté par
michel grossiord sur ce sujet de
l'économie du film français bonne fin de
journée à tous